- Willkommen zurück bei Understanding Quantum
Information and Computation.
Mein Name ist John Watrous und
ich bin der technische Direktor für IBM Quantum Education.
Dies ist die sechste Lektion der Serie und die zweite Lektion in
der zweiten Einheit der Serie, die sich mit Quantenalgorithmen befasst.
In der vorherigen Lektion haben wir das Abfragemodell
der Berechnung besprochen, und wir haben gesehen, dass in diesem Modell Quantenalgorithmen einen
bemerkenswerten Vorteil bieten können
gegenüber klassischen Algorithmen, einschließlich eines exponentiellen Vorteils im Fall von Simons Problem.
Leider hat das Abfragemodell
keine wirklich direkte oder unmittelbare
praktische Relevanz.
Die Vorstellung einer Black Box ist eine sehr nützliche
Abstraktion, wie sich herausstellt, aber wir haben noch einige Arbeit vor uns,
wenn wir die
Erkenntnisse, die wir
aus dem Abfragemodell gewonnen haben, auf einen standardmäßigeren Berechnungskontext anwenden wollen, bei dem Eingaben als Bitfolgen gegeben sind
und nicht als Orakel oder Black Boxes.
Der Hauptzweck dieser Lektion ist es, eine Grundlage
zu schaffen, von der aus wir das tun können.
Hier ist ein Überblick über die Lektion. Für einen Großteil der Lektion werden wir uns auf
den Rechenaufwand konzentrieren,
oder anders gesagt, wie schwierig verschiedene
Rechenaufgaben sind und wie wir diese Schwierigkeit messen können.
Grob gesagt bedeutet das, wie lange wir warten müssen,
bis Berechnungen abgeschlossen sind, und letztendlich welche
Rechenprobleme
wir lösen können und welche
außerhalb unserer Reichweite liegen.
Wir werden mit
ein paar Beispielen beginnen. Der ganzzahligen Faktorisierung und der Berechnung des größten gemeinsamen
Teilers, kurz GCD.
Das sind sehr gute Beispiele zur Veranschaulichung der
zugrundeliegenden Prinzipien, und beide sind auch
sehr relevant für Shors Algorithmus, den wir
in der nächsten Lektion besprechen werden,
sodass wir aus diesen Beispielen
sozusagen doppelten Nutzen ziehen werden.
Dann werden wir den Begriff des Rechenaufwands allgemeiner besprechen und wie wir ihn messen können.
Es gibt viele verschiedene
Möglichkeiten, das zu tun, aber wir werden uns ziemlich eng darauf konzentrieren,
wie wir das mit circuit-Modellen der Berechnung tun können,
insbesondere booleschen circuits
und Quanten-circuits.
Der Fokus liegt hier auf Algorithmen im Gegensatz zu
Computer-Hardware zum Beispiel, und wir werden uns mehr darum kümmern,
wie die Kosten für
die Ausführung eines Algorithmus skalieren, wenn die konkreten Probleminstanzen, auf denen er ausgeführt wird, in der Größe zunehmen, als
darum, wie viele Sekunden,
Minuten oder Stunden eine
bestimmte Berechnung benötigt.
Die Idee, die diesen Standpunkt motiviert, ist, dass Algorithmen
von grundlegender Bedeutung sind.
Bis heute führen wir
immer noch Algorithmen aus, die vor
sehr, sehr langer Zeit entwickelt wurden, und ganz natürlich werden sie eingesetzt
gegen immer größere
Probleminstanzen mit schnellerer und zuverlässigerer Hardware, wenn sich die Technologie weiterentwickelt.
Und die Art und Weise, wie sie skalieren, sagt uns sehr viel darüber,
wie nützlich sie sind und wie nützlich sie weiterhin sein werden.
Im letzten Abschnitt der Lektion wenden wir uns einer entscheidend wichtigen Aufgabe zu, nämlich dem Ausführen klassischer Berechnungen
auf Quantencomputern. Der Grund, warum das wichtig ist, liegt nicht darin, dass wir hoffen, klassische Computer
durch Quantencomputer zu ersetzen,
was in absehbarer Zeit äußerst unwahrscheinlich erscheint, wenn es jemals passiert, sondern weil es
viele interessante Möglichkeiten
für Quantenalgorithmen eröffnet.
Sobald wir wissen, wie klassische Berechnungen
auf Quantencomputern ausgeführt werden, stehen sie Quantenalgorithmen
als Subroutinen zur Verfügung,
sodass wir effektiv
alles, was wir über klassische Algorithmen wissen, im Streben nach Quanten-Rechenvorteilen nutzen können.
Die klassischen Computer, die wir heute haben, sind wahrhaftig technologische Wunderwerke.
Sie sind unglaublich schnell, aber nicht so schnell, dass kein Rechenproblem
außerhalb ihrer Reichweite liegt.
Manche Rechenprobleme
sind so inhärent schwierig, dass obwohl wir Algorithmen haben, um sie zu lösen, kein Computer auf dem Planeten Erde heute
schnell genug ist, diese
Algorithmen auch bei mäßig großen Eingaben innerhalb der Lebensspanne eines Menschen
bis zum Abschluss auszuführen
oder sogar innerhalb der
Lebensdauer der Erde selbst.
Um das näher zu erläutern, schauen wir uns das
ganzzahlige Faktorisierungsproblem an.
Die Problemformulierung ist sehr einfach. Die Eingabe des Problems ist eine ganze Zahl N, die mindestens zwei ist, und die Ausgabe ist die
Primfaktorzerlegung von N,
und das bedeutet eine Liste der Primzahlfaktoren von N zusammen mit den Potenzen, auf die diese Primzahlen erhoben werden müssen,
um N durch
Multiplizieren aller zusammen zu erhalten.
Natürlich können wir die Primfaktoren immer in beliebiger Reihenfolge multiplizieren, aber abgesehen von ihrer Reihenfolge
sind Primfaktorzerlegungen für jede Wahl von N immer eindeutig.
Diese Tatsache wird der
Fundamentalsatz der Arithmetik genannt, und wenn du mehr darüber erfahren möchtest, ist es etwas, das du finden kannst
ganz am Anfang
vieler Bücher über Zahlentheorie.
Als sehr einfaches Beispiel hier ist die Primfaktorzerlegung
der Zahl 12.
Es ist zwei hoch zwei
mal drei hoch eins.
Wenig überraschend kann ein
Computer dir das in einem Augenblick sagen, indem er
iterativ nach Primfaktoren sucht.
Hier ist ein weiteres Beispiel. Ich werde nicht versuchen, diese Zahl zu lesen.
Sie ist etwa 3,4 Quattuordezillionen, und ich muss zugeben, dass es mich seltsam anmutet, dass es überhaupt so einen Namen gibt,
aber jedenfalls hat sie 46 Dezimalstellen und hier kannst du
ihre Primfaktorzerlegung sehen.
Ein Computer kann dir auch das sagen. Ich habe diese Zahl mit der Faktorisierungsmethode faktorisiert, die in der symbolischen Mathematikbibliothek für Python enthalten ist,
und es dauerte ein paar Sekunden, was keine besonders lange Zeit ist, aber es gab eine merkliche Verzögerung.
Und sicherlich findet die factor_n-Methode diese Primfaktorzerlegung nicht durch naives Suchen nach Primfaktoren.
Sie verwendet tatsächlich eine Hybridmethode
aus verschiedenen Algorithmen, einschließlich eines, der
colored row algorithm genannt wird – ein Algorithmus zur Faktorisierung,
der ausgefeilter ist als das naive iterative
Suchen nach Primfaktoren, und obwohl das
wie eine ziemlich große Zahl erscheinen mag,
ist sie als Eingabe für ein Berechnungsproblem eigentlich gar nicht so groß.
Es sind nur 46 Zeichen.
Hier ist noch ein weiteres Beispiel. Es ist eine Zahl mit 309 Dezimalstellen.
Wenn wir sie in Binärschreibweise aufschreiben, hat sie 1.024 Bits, und das ist
der Grund, warum sie RSA1024 heißt.
Die Primfaktorzerlegung dieser Zahl ist derzeit nicht bekannt.
Diese Zahl stammt aus der
RSA-Faktorisierungsherausforderung, die von RSA
Laboratories von 1991 bis 2007 durchgeführt wurde.
Sie boten Geldpreise
für die Primfaktorzerlegungen verschiedener Zahlen zunehmender
Größe an, einschließlich dieser hier, die 100.000 US-Dollar wert war,
aber dieser Preis wurde nie eingelöst.
Die Sicherheit des RSA-Public-Key-Kryptosystems
basiert auf der Schwierigkeit
der Ganzzahlenfaktorisierung.
Wenn du faktorisieren kannst,
kannst du das System knacken, und daher war der Zweck der Herausforderung im Grunde genommen, den
Stand der Technik bei der Faktorisierung zu verfolgen.
Das Fazit ist, dass
die Faktorisierung dieser Zahl jenseits unserer aktuellen Möglichkeiten liegt.
Soweit wir wissen, ist
das Problem selbst zu komplex für klassische Computer,
um es in der Praxis zu lösen.
Die größte bisher faktorisierte RSA-Herausforderungszahl hat übrigens 250 Dezimalstellen.
Es könnte auf dem Bildschirm
etwas schwer zu lesen sein, aber hier ist die
Primfaktorzerlegung von RSA250.
Sie wurde 2020 mit einem Algorithmus namens Zahlkörpersieb durchgeführt, und es war eine kollektive Anstrengung mit Zehntausenden
von Computern auf der ganzen Welt.
Betrachten wir nun ein anderes
Berechnungsproblem, nämlich das Problem, den größten gemeinsamen
Teiler, kurz GGT,
von zwei nicht-negativen ganzen Zahlen zu berechnen.
Hier ist eine Beschreibung des Problems. Die Eingabe besteht diesmal aus zwei
Zahlen, N und M,
und wir gehen davon aus,
dass sie nicht beide gleich null sind.
Das Ziel ist es, den
GGT dieser beiden Zahlen zu berechnen, also die größte ganze Zahl D, die sowohl N als auch M gleichmäßig teilt,
und wenn du über die
Primfaktorzerlegungen von N und M nachdenkst, wirst du feststellen, dass der GGT das Produkt aller Primzahlen ist,
die sowohl N als auch M teilen, potenziert mit dem Minimum der Potenzen, die in den beiden
Primfaktorzerlegungen vorkommen.
Es hängt also mit dem Problem
der Ganzzahlenfaktorisierung zusammen, erweist sich aber als viel, viel einfacher
für Computer zu lösen. Wir können GGTs für Zahlen mit vielen Tausend Stellen
im Handumdrehen berechnen.
Es ist irgendwie sinnlos, dir Beispiele auf dem Bildschirm zeigen zu wollen, weil wir den
gesamten Bildschirm mit Ziffern füllen könnten und immer noch
leicht lösbare Instanzen dieses Problems beschreiben würden.
Aber wenn du interessiert bist, folge dem Link in der Videobeschreibung zur Lehrbuchseite für diese Lektion und du findest Code-Zellen
für die Art von Berechnungen,
über die ich spreche, einschließlich solcher, die
GGTs großer Zahlen berechnen, und du kannst sie selbst ausprobieren.
Die Frage ist, warum ist es möglich, GGTs so einfach zu berechnen?
Und die Antwort auf diese Frage ist, dass wir effiziente
Algorithmen zur Berechnung von GGTs haben.
Darunter ist der Euklidische Algorithmus, der vor über 2.000 Jahren entdeckt wurde, aber es gibt auch andere
effiziente GGT-Algorithmen.
Und natürlich sprechen wir hier von klassischen Algorithmen, also führt das zu einer weiteren Frage.
Könnte es einen effizienten
klassischen Algorithmus für die Ganzzahlenfaktorisierung geben,
der es uns ermöglicht, Zahlen wie RSA1024
im Handumdrehen zu faktorisieren?
Und die Antwort ist ja. Absolut könnte es einen effizienten klassischen
Algorithmus zur Faktorisierung geben, und derzeit kennen wir keine Möglichkeit,
diese Möglichkeit auszuschließen. Alles, was wir sagen können, ist,
dass wir noch keinen gefunden haben.
Bei allen klassischen
Faktorisierungsalgorithmen, die wir kennen, suchen wir im Wesentlichen
noch nach Faktoren,
und das bringt Zahlen wie
RSA1024 außer unsere Reichweite.
Effiziente GGT-Algorithmen
hingegen funktionieren einfach nicht so.
Sie suchen nicht nach einem
größten gemeinsamen Teiler. Sie bauen ihn effektiv mit einem mechanischen Verfahren auf, das in den Kosten grob vergleichbar ist
mit dem Multiplizieren der gleichen
beiden Zahlen, und ich werde später in der Lektion noch etwas mehr dazu sagen.
Natürlich baut das alles
auf Shors Algorithmus auf, den wir in der nächsten Lektion sehen werden – ein effizienter Quantenalgorithmus
für die Berechnung von Primfaktorzerlegungen, aber wir haben noch
einiges zu behandeln, bevor wir dorthin gelangen.
Als Nächstes werden wir
über ein mathematisches Rahmenwerk sprechen, mit dem wir die Rechenkosten
verschiedener Algorithmen messen können,
einschließlich solcher, über die wir bereits gesprochen haben.
Um es klar zu sagen: Wir werden uns sehr eng auf circuits konzentrieren, was nur ein kleiner Teil
eines viel umfassenderen Themas ist.
Fangen wir mit einer sehr übergeordneten Betrachtung einer gewöhnlichen Berechnung
aus der vorherigen Lektion an, was insbesondere bedeutet, dass wir nicht über
Query-Probleme nachdenken,
sondern über
Probleme, bei denen die Eingabe explizit als Binärstring gegeben ist.
Wie ich in der vorherigen Lektion gesagt habe, könnten wir natürlich
andere Symbole zulassen, wenn wir wollten, aber lass uns die Dinge einfach halten und bei Binärstrings bleiben
sowohl für die Eingabe als auch für die Ausgabe.
Die Berechnung selbst könnte auf verschiedene Arten modelliert oder beschrieben werden, beispielsweise mit dem Turing-
Maschinenmodell der Berechnung,
Booleschen circuits, quantum circuits oder Programmen, die in
einer Sprache wie Python oder einer anderen Sprache deiner Wahl geschrieben sind.
Wie ich eben gesagt habe, werden wir uns auf
circuits konzentrieren, Boolesche und Quanten-circuits.
Lass uns zunächst etwas mehr Zeit damit verbringen, über die Eingabe und die Ausgabe zu sprechen, von denen wir annehmen, dass sie Binärstrings sind.
Mit Binärstrings können wir viele verschiedene Arten von
mathematischen Objekten kodieren, wie Zahlen, Vektoren,
Matrizen, Graphen,
Beschreibungen von Molekülen zum Beispiel, sowie Listen all dieser Objekte und weiterer.
Als sehr einfaches Beispiel: Wenn wir nicht-negative
ganze Zahlen als Binärstrings kodieren wollen, können wir die Binärdarstellung verwenden.
In dieser Tabelle siehst du die ersten 13
nicht-negativen ganzen Zahlen zusammen mit ihren binären
Darstellungen oder Kodierungen.
In der dritten Spalte kannst du die Länge
jeder dieser Kodierungen sehen, was einfach die Gesamtzahl der Bits ist, die du für die Kodierung benötigst,
und hier ist eine einfache Formel, die dir genau sagt, wie viele Bits
im Allgemeinen für eine beliebige nicht-negative ganze Zahl N benötigt werden.
Beachte insbesondere, dass
die Länge der Kodierung im Allgemeinen viel kleiner
als die Zahl selbst ist.
Sie ist logarithmisch in der Zahl.
RSA1024 hat zum Beispiel eine Kodierung mit der Länge 1.024, aber die Zahl selbst ist
natürlich viel größer als das.
Dieses Kodierungsschema funktioniert
für nicht-negative ganze Zahlen, aber wenn wir
beliebige ganze Zahlen behandeln wollen, einschließlich negativer, können wir
einfach ein Vorzeichenbit anhängen.
Wir können auch eine beliebige Anzahl führender Nullen in diesen Kodierungen zulassen, wenn wir möchten, dass die Kodierungen
einen Block von Bits oder ein Register fester Größe füllen
solange es groß genug ist. Das ist manchmal sehr praktisch.
Dies ist nicht die einzige Möglichkeit, ganze Zahlen als Bitstrings zu kodieren.
Es gibt andere Möglichkeiten, wie du es tun könntest, aber dies ist eine ziemlich
standardmäßige Art, es zu tun.
Für andere Arten von Objekten, die die Eingaben oder Ausgaben der Rechenprobleme
bilden könnten, an denen wir interessiert sind, können wir
andere Kodierungsschemata entwickeln.
Denk zum Beispiel daran,
wie du einen Vektor oder einen Graphen als Binärstring kodieren könntest, oder denk daran, wie du
zwei Binärstrings in
einen einzigen Binärstring kodieren könntest, indem du nur das Symbol Null und Eins verwendest, ohne ein Leerzeichen oder ein anderes Symbol,
um die beiden Strings zu trennen. Es gibt sicherlich Möglichkeiten,
diese Dinge zu tun, und tatsächlich haben wir eine Menge Freiheit
darin, wie genau wir es tun.
Oft wird es keinen einzigen Standard oder allgemein vereinbarten Weg geben, das, worüber wir sprechen,
als Binärstring zu kodieren,
aber das ist in Ordnung, wir können einfach einen auswählen oder einen neuen erfinden, wenn wir das bevorzugen.
Aus rein formaler Sicht betrachten wir Berechnungen als im Wesentlichen mechanische Transformationen von Bitstrings
und die Besonderheiten der von uns verwendeten
Kodierungsschemata sind sicherlich auf einer gewissen Ebene wichtig.
Wenn wir jedoch Algorithmen entwerfen und
analysieren, machen wir uns normalerweise nicht allzu viele Gedanken über die Besonderheiten der
Kodierungsschemata.
Wenn du zwei verschiedene Personen bittest, eine Möglichkeit zu entwickeln, sagen wir, Moleküle eines bestimmten
Typs als Binärstrings zu kodieren,
könntest du erwarten, dass sie unterschiedliche Wege finden, aber wenn es vernünftige Personen wären, die wussten, was sie taten,
könntest du auch vernünftigerweise erwarten, dass es ein ziemlich
einfacher Rechenvorgang wäre, zwischen den beiden Kodierungsschemata hin und her zu übersetzen,
der höchstwahrscheinlich eine sehr
geradlinige Berechnung erfordert, die im Vergleich zur eigentlichen Berechnung,
an der wir interessiert sind, recht einfach wäre.
Kurz gesagt: Die Details der von uns verwendeten Kodierungsschemata sind oft recht zweitrangig, und unser Fokus liegt auf den
Algorithmen selbst.
Nichts davon wird übrigens ein Problem für diese Lektion sein. Wir werden uns hauptsächlich auf Probleme konzentrieren, die ganze Zahlen betreffen, von denen wir annehmen, dass sie binär kodiert sind,
aber es ist etwas, das man im Hinterkopf behalten sollte.
Im Allgemeinen bezieht sich die Eingabelänge für jede Art von Problem, über das wir sprechen, auf
die Anzahl der Bits, die wir benötigen, um die Eingabe zu kodieren,
und wir betrachten die Eingabelänge als die Größe der Instanz des jeweiligen Problems, über das wir nachdenken.
Nun lass uns die
Berechnung selbst betrachten, die durch das
blaue Rechteck in dieser Abbildung dargestellt wird.
Die Art und Weise, wie wir
die Kosten dieser Berechnung messen, besteht darin, die Anzahl der elementaren Operationen zu zählen, die sie erfordert.
Intuitiv gesprochen ist eine elementare Operation eine, die eine kleine feste
Anzahl von Bits oder qubits umfasst
und schnell und einfach ausgeführt werden kann, wie das Berechnen des AND von
zwei Bits zum Beispiel.
Auf formaler Ebene gibt es
verschiedene Möglichkeiten, eine elementare Operation zu definieren, je nachdem, welches
Rechenmodell wir verwenden.
Zum Beispiel könnte eine elementare Operation ein Schritt einer Turing-Maschine sein, wenn wir dieses Modell verwenden würden.
Für die Zwecke dieser Lektion werden wir uns auf circuit-Modelle konzentrieren, wie ich bereits erwähnt habe, und speziell auf Quanten- und Boolesche circuits.
Wenn wir mit circuits arbeiten, ist es üblich, dass wir jedes gate als eine elementare Operation betrachten.
Wir haben bisher in der Reihe verschiedene Quanten-gates gesehen,
darunter X-, Y- und Z-gates, Hadamard-gates, S- und T-gates,
controlled-NOT-gates, Swap-gates, Toffoli-gates und Fredkin-gates.
Wir haben auch über Query-gates im Kontext des Query-Modells gesprochen, aber wir werden in dieser Lektion nicht im Query-Modell arbeiten, also brauchen wir uns
jetzt keine Gedanken über Query-gates zu machen.
Wir haben auch gesehen, dass jede unitäre Operation auf einer beliebigen Anzahl von qubits
als gate betrachtet werden kann, wenn wir das wollen.
Für die Zwecke der Kostenmessung wird das jedoch nicht sehr hilfreich sein, also werden wir einfach
eine Menge von gates auswählen
und diese Menge als unsere Menge elementarer Operationen betrachten.
Zunächst werden wir die
einzelnen qubit-unitären gates einbeziehen, die du hier siehst,
nämlich X-, Y- und Z-gates,
Hadamard-gates und S- und T-gates, sowie ihre Inversen
oder konjugierten Transponierten.
Wir brauchen eigentlich nicht alle diese gates. Sobald wir Hadamard- und T-gates haben, können wir die restlichen implementieren,
aber der Einfachheit halber werden wir sie alle einbeziehen.
Wir werden auch controlled-NOT-gates einbeziehen, und diese werden die einzigen
gates mit mehreren qubits in unserer Menge sein.
Und schließlich werden wir Einzelqubit-Standardbasismessungen einbeziehen, damit wir tatsächlich klassische Informationen
aus unseren circuits gewinnen können.
Wenn wir uns nur auf die unitären gates konzentrieren und die
Messungen für einen Moment vergessen, erhalten wir, was als
universelles gate-Set bezeichnet wird.
Das bedeutet, dass
jede unitäre Operation auf einer beliebigen Anzahl von qubits
entweder genau implementiert werden kann
oder beliebig nahe daran
mit einem Quanten-circuit, der nur aus diesen gates aufgebaut ist.
Mit anderen Worten, das ist ein
ausreichend gutes Set von gates, mit dem wir jede unitäre
Operation aufbauen können.
Nicht unbedingt exakt, aber wir können eine so gute
Annäherung erreichen, wie wir wollen.
Das kann viele gates erfordern, und es ist eigentlich nicht allzu schwer zu begründen, dass das manchmal viele
gates erfordern muss,
aber dennoch ist es immer möglich.
Es ist jedoch keine einfache Sache zu beweisen, dass dies ein universelles gate-Set ist, und wir werden nicht besprechen, wie
das in der Reihe gemacht wird,
aber es ist eine ziemlich bekannte Tatsache und es gibt tatsächlich verschiedene
Wege, wie es bewiesen werden kann.
Es gibt auch andere gate-Sets, die manchmal anstelle dieses verwendet werden,
wie Toffoli-gates, Hadamard-gates und S-gates zusätzlich zu Messungen,
aber das ist eine ziemlich standardmäßige Wahl.
Zusammenfassend sind das also
die Quantenoperationen, die wir als elementar betrachten werden.
Für Boolesche circuits
werden wir diese vier gates als
elementare Operationen betrachten: AND-gates, OR-gates, NOT-gates und FANOUT.
FANOUT wird übrigens nicht
immer als gate gezählt, aber es wird
wichtig für uns sein, das zu tun, wie wir später in der Lektion sehen werden.
Ähnlich wie bei unserem
standardmäßigen Quanten-gate-Set ist dieses Set ein wenig redundant.
Du brauchst nicht sowohl AND als auch OR. Du kannst entweder eines mit dem anderen und drei NOT-gates erstellen,
aber es schadet nicht, beide einzubeziehen, und es ist einfach praktisch.
Wie du vielleicht bereits weißt, ist das ein universelles gate-Set
für deterministische Berechnungen, was bedeutet, dass jede Funktion
von Bits zu Bits
mit einem Booleschen circuit implementiert werden kann, der aus gates dieser Sammlung zusammengesetzt ist.
Noch einmal, genau wie bei
Quanten-circuits, bedeutet das nicht, dass jede Funktion effizient
durch einen Booleschen circuit implementiert werden kann,
und tatsächlich können die meisten Funktionen
nur mit sehr großen circuits
implementiert werden, aus dem einfachen Grund, dass es sehr viele Funktionen gibt
und sie nicht alle kleine circuits haben können. Es gibt einfach nicht genug
kleine circuits für alle.
Universalität ist in diesem Fall
einfacher zu beweisen als im Quantenfall, wie sich herausstellt.
Wenn du also noch nicht
weißt, wie man es beweist, denk darüber nach und
schau, ob du es herausfinden kannst, wenn du dazu geneigt bist.
Nun, da wir uns für die
gates entschieden haben, die wir zulassen werden und die wir als
elementare Operationen betrachten werden, können wir darüber nachdenken, wie viele davon
benötigt werden, um
verschiedene Berechnungen durchzuführen.
Dazu werden wir
diese Definition für die Größe eines circuits verwenden.
Diese Definition funktioniert sowohl für
Boolesche als auch für Quanten-circuits und ist sehr einfach.
Die Größe eines circuits ist die
Gesamtzahl der gates, die er hat.
Wenn wir zum Beispiel zu
demselben Beispiel zurückkehren, das wir schon mehrmals gesehen haben, nämlich unserem Booleschen circuit zur Berechnung des exklusiven ODER von zwei Bits,
sehen wir, dass er die Größe sieben hat,
weil es sieben gates gibt, zwei FANOUT-gates, zwei NOT-gates,
zwei AND-gates und ein OR-gate. Wenn wir uns entschieden hätten, FANOUT-gates nicht zu zählen, was üblich ist, hätte er die Größe fünf,
aber wir werden FANOUT-gates zählen, also ist seine Größe sieben.
Die Größe eines circuits
entspricht der Anzahl der elementaren Operationen,
die wir ausführen müssen.
Wenn wir also
diese Operationen sequenziell ausführen würden, würde uns die Größe sagen,
wie lange es dauern würde,
du kannst dir die circuit-Größe also als sequentielle Laufzeit vorstellen.
So werden wir
die Rechenkosten für die Zwecke dieser Lektion messen.
Es gibt jedoch eine weitere Eigenschaft
von circuits, die auch als die benötigte Zeit
betrachtet werden kann, um einen circuit auszuführen – nämlich die Tiefe des circuits.
Genauer gesagt ist die Tiefe
die maximale Anzahl von gates auf einem beliebigen Pfad von einem Eingabe-Draht zu einem Ausgabe-Draht,
was der Anzahl der gate-Schichten entspricht, die wir
benötigen, um den circuit zu erstellen, wobei eine Schicht eine Gruppe von gates bezeichnet,
die gleichzeitig ausgeführt werden können, weil sie
keine gemeinsamen Drähte haben.
Unser circuit
von vorhin hat zum Beispiel die Tiefe vier, und wir können direkt im Diagramm erkennen, dass es vier Schichten gibt.
Die FANOUT-gates können
gleichzeitig ausgeführt werden, die NOT-gates können
gleichzeitig ausgeführt werden und die AND-gates können
ebenfalls gleichzeitig ausgeführt werden.
Wir können also die circuit-Tiefe als parallele Laufzeit betrachten.
Die circuit-Tiefe ist sicherlich ein interessantes und wichtiges Konzept, und es gibt einige sehr
ausgefeilte Techniken, mit denen man
die erforderliche Tiefe für bestimmte Berechnungen reduzieren kann, manchmal sogar ganz erheblich – aber das ist ein fortgeschrittenes Thema,
und wir werden in dieser Serie nicht viel mehr darüber sagen.
Also messen wir die Rechenkosten wieder
in Bezug auf die circuit-Größe, mit anderen Worten:
die Anzahl der elementaren Operationen, die zur Durchführung einer Berechnung erforderlich sind.
Zu Beginn der Lektion haben wir über das Problem der ganzzahligen
Faktorisierung gesprochen und gesehen, dass die Zeit, die ein Algorithmus zur Lösung dieses Problems benötigt,
mit wachsender Eingabelänge zunehmen kann – und das ist typischerweise
das Problem, auf das wir uns konzentrieren,
wenn wir Algorithmen analysieren.
Das heißt, wir interessieren uns dafür, wie die Kosten für das Ausführen von Algorithmen skalieren, wenn die Eingaben immer größer werden.
Natürlich ist diese Art von Skalierung nicht das Einzige, was zählt.
Wir könnten zum Beispiel einfach daran interessiert sein, die Faktoren
von RSA1024 zu finden, und das war's.
In einem solchen Fall würden wir also über eine
einzelne Probleminstanz sprechen, bei der nichts wächst.
Aber wenn wir über Algorithmen nachdenken, ist die Art und Weise, wie ihre Kosten
skalieren, sehr wichtig, und sie verrät uns viel
über die Algorithmen.
Diese Sichtweise ist
konsistent mit der Idee, dass Algorithmen grundlegend sind, und wie ich vorhin erwähnt habe,
werden sie mit der Zeit und dem technologischen Fortschritt gegen
immer größere Eingaben eingesetzt werden.
Beachte jedoch, dass Eingaben für Rechenprobleme
zwar an Größe wachsen können, circuits jedoch nicht wachsen.
Jeder circuit hat eine feste Größe.
Und aus diesem Grund benötigen wir, wenn wir einen
Algorithmus mit circuits beschreiben wollen, tatsächlich eine Familie von circuits dafür,
und unter einer Familie von circuits verstehen wir eine Sammlung von circuits, die immer größer wird, damit wir Eingaben
aufnehmen können, die immer größer werden. Betrachten wir zum Beispiel einen klassischen deterministischen Algorithmus
für das ganzzahlige Faktorisierungsproblem, vielleicht einen, der auf Probedivision basiert, aber die Details spielen für dieses Beispiel nicht wirklich eine Rolle.
für dieses Beispiel.
Wir könnten prinzipiell
einen solchen Algorithmus mithilfe einer Familie von Booleschen circuits beschreiben, wobei wir, wenn wir eine Zahl faktorisieren wollen,
deren Binärdarstellung N Bits hat, den circuit CN aus unserer Familie nehmen und die Zahl eingeben,
die wir faktorisieren wollen,
in die Eingabe-Bits dieses circuits.
Manchmal könnten wir diese circuits
auf unterschiedliche Weise parametrisieren, sodass es nicht immer der Fall ist, dass der N-te circuit N Eingabe-Bits hat.
Aber das ist eine ziemlich typische Vorgehensweise. Wenn die Eingabelängen länger werden, würden wir natürlich erwarten, dass die circuits
in dieser Familie größer werden,
was die Tatsache widerspiegelt,
dass das Faktorisieren von Vier-Bit-Zahlen zum Beispiel viel einfacher ist als das Faktorisieren von 1.024-Bit-Zahlen.
Daher messen wir die Kosten eines solchen
Algorithmus mit einer Funktion, die uns sagt, wie viele
elementare Operationen
wir für jede mögliche Eingabelänge benötigen, und wir können dies sowohl für klassische als auch für Quantenalgorithmen tun.
Betrachten wir als Beispiel das Problem der ganzzahligen Addition, das sicherlich viel
einfacher ist als das Faktorisieren
oder sogar das Berechnen von GCDs.
Um die Dinge einfach zu halten, nehmen wir an, dass sowohl N als auch
M nicht-negative ganze Zahlen sind und dass sie dargestellt werden
durch Binärstrings gleicher Länge.
Wie könnten wir Boolesche circuits bauen, die diese beiden Zahlen addieren?
Fangen wir mit einem Algorithmus an – dem Standardalgorithmus für die Addition, der das Basis-Zwei-Analogon der Methode ist,
die wir vermutlich alle für die Addition von Zahlen mit
Bleistift und Papier gelernt haben. Wir beginnen also mit den
niederwertigsten Bits,
addieren sie, und das ergibt das
niederwertigste Bit des Ergebnisses zusammen mit einem Übertrag-Bit,
das wir berücksichtigen müssen,
wenn wir zur nächsten Position übergehen. Und wir fahren fort, uns durch die Bits zu bewegen, dabei Ausgabe-Bits
zusammen mit Übertrag-Bits erzeugend,
bis wir am Ende angelangt sind.
Diese Methode lässt sich
ziemlich direkt in Booleschen circuits ausdrücken.
Eine Möglichkeit, darüber nachzudenken, ist, mit einem kleinen circuit zum Addieren zweier einstelliger ganzer Zahlen zu beginnen.
Das ergibt eine Zahl
zwischen null und zwei, wobei das niederwertigere Bit das XOR der Eingabe-Bits ist.
und das höherwertige Bit, oder das Übertragungsbit, wenn du es so bevorzugst, ist das UND der beiden Eingangsbits.
Manchmal bezeichnen wir einen circuit, der diese
beiden Operationen zusammen ausführt, als Halbaddierer.
Das funktioniert gut, wenn es
nur zwei Eingangsbits gibt, aber wenn wir ganze Zahlen mit mehr als nur einem Bit addieren wollen,
müssen wir die Übertragungsbits
irgendwie handhaben.
Was wir tun können, ist, zwei Halbaddierer
hintereinanderzuschalten und das ODER der
erzeugten Übertragungsbits zu nehmen, um einen sogenannten Volladdierer zu erstellen,
der im Grunde ein boolescher circuit ist, um drei einstellige
Binärzahlen zusammenzuaddieren.
Und sobald wir einen Volladdierer haben, können wir Zahlen
einfach durch Hintereinanderschalten addieren, vom niederwertigsten Bit
zum höchstwertigen Bit. Wir implementieren im Grunde nur den Standard-Additionsalgorithmus und nutzen die Volladdierer, um
die Übertragungsbits zu verarbeiten.
Was sind also die Kosten dieser Berechnung?
Nun, wir brauchen sieben elementare
gates für jedes XOR-gate, das bedeutet 10 gates für einen Halbaddierer
und daher 21 gates für einen Volladdierer, also zwei Halbaddierer plus ein ODER-gate.
Am Ende des Tages gilt: Wenn unsere Eingabezahlen beide AND Bits haben, brauchen wir einen Halbaddierer für
das niederwertigste Bit
und einen Volladdierer für jedes andere Bit, und das Endergebnis sind 21 mal N minus eins plus 10, also 21 N minus 11 gates insgesamt.
Wenn wir uns aus irgendeinem Grund entscheiden würden,
die FANOUT-gates nicht zu zählen und die XOR-
gates in unsere gate-Menge aufzunehmen, bräuchten wir insgesamt fünf N minus
drei gates.
Es ist schön zu wissen, wie viele gates oder elementare Operationen benötigt werden, um verschiedene Berechnungen durchzuführen,
wie wir es gerade bei der ganzzahligen Addition gesehen haben.
Und natürlich müssen wir diese Details kennen, wenn wir diese Berechnungen tatsächlich implementieren wollen.
Aber wenn wir immer so detailliert vorgehen, besonders bei komplizierteren
Algorithmen, werden wir sehr schnell in Details versinken,
die in vielen Fällen nur
sekundäre Bedeutung haben.
Eine Möglichkeit, die Dinge zu vereinfachen, die in der
Analyse von Algorithmen sehr verbreitet ist, ist die Verwendung der Groß-O-Notation,
die es uns ermöglicht,
Wachstumsraten auf eine ziemlich einfache Art
auszudrücken und zu vergleichen, was sehr praktisch ist.
Und hier siehst du die Definition, die dieser Notation zugrunde liegt.
Angenommen, wir haben
zwei Funktionen G und H, die wir der Einfachheit halber als nicht-negative ganzzahlige
Werte annehmen können,
obwohl das eigentlich nicht erforderlich ist. Vielleicht stellen G und H zum Beispiel die Kosten verschiedener Berechnungen dar.
Wir sagen dann, dass G Groß-O von H ist, was traditionell
mit einem Gleichheitszeichen so geschrieben wird.
Wenn G von N höchstens eine
positive Konstante C mal H von N ist, solange N groß genug ist.
Es geht also darum, was
passiert, wenn N groß wird.
Formal bedeutet „groß genug", dass es eine Wahl von N null gibt, sodass die Ungleichung wahr ist,
wann immer N mindestens N null ist.
Der Schlüssel hier ist, dass diese
Zahlen C und N null fest sind.
Sie können beliebige Zahlen sein,
aber egal was sie sind, sie können sich nicht ändern, während N wächst.
Wenn du diese Art von Definition noch nie gesehen hast,
könnte es etwas Gewöhnung erfordern, und du kannst Ressourcen finden,
die dieses Konzept erklären
viel detaillierter,
als ich es in dieser Lektion kann.
Normalerweise wählen wir
die Funktion H so einfach wie möglich, um etwas darüber auszudrücken, wie schnell die Funktion G wächst.
Zum Beispiel ist die Funktion, deren Wert 17 mal N hoch drei minus 257 ist,
mal N-Quadrat plus
65.537 Groß-O von N hoch drei, und du kannst dieses
Beispiel auf die Definition anpassen,
indem du C und N null entsprechend wählst.
Wenn wir zum Beispiel C als 18 wählen, haben wir,
dass der Ausdruck tatsächlich höchstens 18 mal N hoch drei ist,
solange N groß genug ist.
Um diese Notation mit dem
Beispiel der ganzzahligen Addition zu verknüpfen: Was wir jetzt sagen können ist, dass es eine Familie von booleschen circuits gibt,
um nicht-negative ganze Zahlen zu addieren, sodass die Größe des N-ten circuits, also des circuits, der
für Eingaben der Länge N funktioniert,
Groß-O von N ist. Die tatsächliche Größe des CN
gemäß unserer Analyse war 21 mal N minus 11,
aber das ist Groß-O von N.
Nun ist es nicht immer klug, Details so wegzuwerfen, aber hier macht es Sinn,
weil es das Wesentliche des Standard-Additionsalgorithmus offenbart, nämlich dass seine Kosten linear skalieren
in der Größe der Zahlen,
die wir addieren, und dieser Ausdruck ist nicht empfindlich gegenüber einigen
Details auf niedriger Ebene unseres Modells,
wie zum Beispiel genau welche gates wir als elementare Operationen betrachten.
Wenn wir zum Beispiel entscheiden würden, dass XOR-gates als
elementare Operationen gelten sollten, oder dass FANOUT-gates nicht
als gates zählen sollten, oder beides,
würde immer noch gelten, dass die ganzzahlige Addition mit den Kosten Groß-O von N berechnet werden kann.
Hier ist ein weiteres Beispiel für
ein Berechnungsproblem: die Multiplikation ganzer Zahlen.
Ähnlich wie bei der Addition können wir fragen, was die Kosten
dieser Berechnung sind.
Wenn wir den Standard-
Multiplikationsalgorithmus betrachten, also das Binäranalogon der Methode zur Multiplikation von Zahlen,
die in der Grundschule gelehrt wird,
was im Grunde nur
Verschieben und Addieren ist, wenn wir mit Zahlen in Binärform arbeiten, stellen wir fest, dass es Boolean-circuits der Größe groß-O von N-Quadrat gibt
zum Multiplizieren von N-Bit-Ganzzahlen.
Das werde ich hier nicht im Detail durchgehen. Natürlich sind die circuits
etwas komplizierter als die für die Addition, aber wenn du dir überlegst, wie
der Standard-
Multiplikationsalgorithmus funktioniert, sollte das keine Überraschung sein.
Im Wesentlichen müssen wir
etwa N Additionen durchführen, von denen jede lineare Kosten hat, und so erhalten wir
insgesamt quadratische Kosten.
Das lässt sich verallgemeinern. Wenn eine der Zahlen N Bits hat und die andere M Bits, dann benötigen wir circuits der
Größe groß-O von N mal M.
Hier verwenden wir übrigens tatsächlich eine Erweiterung der groß-O-Notation mit mehreren Variablen, aber sie lässt sich so erweitern,
und wenn du an den
spezifischen Details interessiert bist, verweise ich dich auf die Lehrbuchinhalte
zur Lektion, die wieder in der
Videobeschreibung verlinkt sind.
Es ist tatsächlich möglich,
zwei N-Bit-Ganzzahlen auf eine Weise miteinander zu multiplizieren,
die dem Standard-Multiplikationsalgorithmus asymptotisch überlegen ist.
Insbesondere multipliziert der Schonhage-Strassen-Multiplikationsalgorithmus
zwei N-Bit-Ganzzahlen mit Kosten von groß-O von
N mal der Länge von N
mal der Länge der Länge von N. Je größer N wird, also
bei Zehntausenden von Bits,
ist das tatsächlich eine effizientere
Methode zum Multiplizieren, aber sie ist kompliziert und der Overhead macht sie für kleinere Zahlen unpraktisch.
Fügen wir also die Multiplikation
zu unserer Beispielliste hinzu.
Und der Einfachheit halber listen wir die Kosten des Standard-Multiplikationsalgorithmus auf, die groß-O von N-Quadrat betragen.
Also konzentrieren wir uns wieder auf das Wesentliche dieser Kosten, nämlich dass sie quadratisch skalieren
oder sub-quadratisch, wenn wir asymptotisch überlegene Methoden verwenden.
Wir können auch das
Problem der ganzzahligen Division betrachten, das auf dem Bildschirm präzise formuliert ist.
Hier geht es darum, einen Quotienten und einen Rest zu berechnen, die Antwort besteht also
aus zwei Ganzzahlen, Q und R.
Auch hier gibt es einen Standard-
algorithmus für die Division, der ebenfalls quadratische
Kosten hat, und wie bei der Multiplikation
gibt es tatsächlich asymptotisch
überlegene Algorithmen.
Wie schneiden also GCD-Algorithmen im Vergleich ab?
Nun, Euklids Algorithmus hat
sich als quadratisch in den Kosten herausgestellt, und das ist das, was ich
früher in der Lektion meinte, als ich sagte, dass wir GCDs berechnen können
mit ungefähr denselben Kosten wie das Multiplizieren zweier Zahlen.
Auch hier gibt es
asymptotisch überlegene Algorithmen ähnlicher Art wie bei
Addition und Multiplikation,
obwohl die Kosten in diesem Fall etwas
höher sind, zumindest soweit wir wissen.
Ich möchte noch ein weiteres Beispiel für ein Problem nennen, das wir dieser Liste hinzufügen können, und zwar die modulare Exponentiation.
Hier gibt es drei Eingabe-
zahlen, K, M und N, und das Ziel ist es, N
hoch K modulo-M zu berechnen,
was den Rest
nach der Division durch M bedeutet.
Es ist überhaupt nicht offensichtlich, aber wir können modulare
Exponentiation zu qubit-Kosten berechnen, d.h. groß-O von N-Kubik
für N-Bit-Ganzzahlen.
Die Vorgehensweise dabei ist nicht, zunächst N hoch K zu berechnen und dann den Rest zu berechnen.
Selbst das Aufschreiben von N hoch K könnte exponentiell viele Bits erfordern, also funktioniert dieser Ansatz nicht.
Stattdessen können wir einen Algorithmus
namens Power-Algorithmus verwenden, der auch als wiederholtes Quadrieren bezeichnet wird, wobei alles modulo-M durchgeführt wird
und wir die Bits von
K verwenden, um iterativ zu quadrieren und zu multiplizieren, sodass alles funktioniert.
Das ist also teurer als die anderen,
aber wir können dennoch modulare Exponentiation recht schnell bei Zahlen
mit vielen Tausenden von Bits durchführen.
Wie vergleichen sich also die Kosten dieser Aufgaben mit der ganzzahligen Faktorisierung?
Wenn wir einfach anfangen und
an Probedivision denken, bei der wir zunächst prüfen, ob zwei ein Faktor der Eingabezahl ist,
und dann drei prüfen und so weiter, erhalten wir einen ziemlich
teuren Algorithmus, groß-O von N-Quadrat mal
zwei hoch N durch zwei.
Jede Division benötigt quadratische Zeit, und im schlimmsten Fall müssen wir nach Primfaktoren bis zur Quadratwurzel der Eingabezahl suchen,
und daher kommt das N
durch zwei. Wenn wir an diesem Punkt noch keinen
Primfaktor gefunden haben, können wir einfach aufhören, denn dann
muss die Eingabezahl selbst prim sein.
Das ist extrem teuer, weil N als Exponent in diesem Ausdruck vorkommt, das heißt, dieser
Algorithmus hat exponentielle Kosten.
Im Gegensatz dazu haben alle Beispiele in diesem Kasten hier das, was wir polynomiale Kosten nennen, bei denen N auf eine Potenz erhoben wird,
aber diese Potenz ist immer eine feste Zahl, die nicht wächst, wenn
die Eingabelänge wächst.
In diesen Fällen sind die Potenzen
eins, zwei und drei.
Ich werde gleich auf polynomiale versus exponentielle Kosten zurückkommen, aber zuerst wollen wir abschließen,
was wir über Faktorisierung wissen.
Ich habe früher das
Zahlkörpersieb erwähnt, das der beste
Faktorisierungsalgorithmus ist, den wir in Bezug auf die Skalierung seiner Kosten haben.
Die Kosten dieses Algorithmus sind tatsächlich nicht rigoros bewiesen, da er mit einigen offenen Fragen der Zahlentheorie zusammenhängt,
aber es wird vermutet, dass er
Kosten hat, die so aussehen.
Diesmal steht das groß-O im Exponenten, aber ich werde dieses
Detail unter den Tisch kehren.
Das Wichtigste ist, dass es deutlich besser ist
als die Probedivision, denn obwohl N
im Exponenten vorkommt,
wird zur Potenz 1/3 erhoben, und das führt zu deutlich geringeren Kosten – und deshalb kann dieser Algorithmus
Zahlen wie RSA250 verarbeiten, während die Probedivision
das definitiv nicht kann.
Er ist jedoch noch exponentiell in dem Sinne, dass eine Potenz von N in einem Exponenten auftaucht, und daher
kann er immer noch keine
Zahlen wie RSA1024 verarbeiten.
Lass mich jetzt noch etwas mehr über polynomielle Kosten
im Vergleich zu exponentiellen Kosten sagen.
Wir sagen, dass ein Algorithmus
polynomielle Kosten hat, wenn seine Kosten O(N hoch B) sind,
wobei B eine beliebige positive Zahl sein kann, entscheidend ist aber, dass B fest sein muss, das heißt, es darf sich nicht ändern,
wenn die Eingabelänge N wächst.
Bei den Beispielen, die wir gerade eben gesehen haben – also ganzzahlige Addition, Multiplikation, Division, Berechnung von GCDs
und modulare Exponentiation –
war B entweder
eins, zwei oder drei.
Das sind also alles
Algorithmen mit polynomiellen Kosten.
Aber wenn wir allgemeiner von polynomiellen
Kosten sprechen, kann B eine beliebige positive Zahl sein.
Es könnte sogar eine Million sein,
aber es muss fest sein.
Als sehr grobe Abstraktion werden Algorithmen mit polynomiellen
Kosten typischerweise als effiziente Algorithmen angesehen.
Das ist definitiv eine Vereinfachung, aber als grobe Richtlinie kannst du dir einen
Algorithmus mit polynomiellen Kosten
als einen vorstellen, der die Struktur eines Problems auf irgendeine Weise nutzt, um eine Lösung zu konstruieren, anstatt einen Brute-Force-Ansatz
oder eine erschöpfende Suche
über einen sehr großen Raum zu verwenden.
Natürlich würde ein Algorithmus, dessen Kosten mit N hoch einer Million
bei Eingaben der Länge N skalieren,
vernünftigerweise nicht
als effizient angesehen werden, und wir würden nicht erwarten,
ihn auf großen Eingaben ausführen zu können.
Aber trotzdem muss selbst ein N-hoch-eine-Million-Algorithmus etwas Cleveres tun, das auf irgendeine Weise die Struktur widerspiegelt
des jeweiligen Problems, das er löst, um die exponentielle Skalierung der Kosten zu vermeiden, die mit einer
erschöpfenden Suche über einen großen Bereich verbunden wäre.
Und in der Praxis ist die Identifizierung eines Algorithmus mit polynomiellen Kosten wirklich nur ein erster
Schritt in Richtung Effizienz.
Wenn ein Problem wichtig ist
und jemand den allerersten Algorithmus mit polynomiellen
Kosten dafür entdeckt – vielleicht mit einem sehr großen Exponenten –
kann man ziemlich sicher sein, dass Algorithmenentwicker
Verbesserungen finden werden, die diesen Exponenten senken.
Im Wesentlichen kannst du
die Existenz eines Algorithmus mit polynomiellen Kosten
für ein Problem als Nachweis der Machbarkeit
betrachten, dieses Problem zu lösen,
bei hinreichend großen Eingaben, aber es könnte noch viel Arbeit erforderlich sein, um echte Effizienz zu erreichen.
In der Komplexitätstheorie sagt man typischerweise, dass die Kosten eines Algorithmus
subexponentiell skalieren, wenn die Kosten O(2 hoch N
hoch Epsilon) für jede positive reelle Zahl Epsilon sind, und wenn es nicht subexponentiell ist,
dann ist es exponentiell, oder es könnte sogar superexponentiell sein, wie 2 hoch 2 hoch N,
was doppelt exponentiell ist,
aber solange die Ausgabe nicht superexponentiell lang ist, kann jedes Problem tatsächlich durch einen booleschen circuit
mit exponentiellen Kosten berechnet werden, wie sich herausstellt. Die wichtige Unterscheidung hier ist also zwischen polynomiellen
und exponentiellen Kosten.
Wir kennen keine klassischen Algorithmen mit subexponentiellen Kosten für
die ganzzahlige Faktorisierung.
Zum Beispiel sind die Kosten des Zahlkörpersiebs nicht O(2 hoch N
hoch Epsilon), wenn Epsilon 1/3 oder kleiner ist,
es erfüllt also diese Definition nicht.
Es ist zweifellos ein sehr cleverer Algorithmus, aber es ist immer noch ein Sieb, und wir suchen immer noch effektiv
über einen sehr großen Raum, um Faktoren einer gegebenen Zahl zu identifizieren.
Wie wir in der nächsten Lektion sehen werden, gibt es tatsächlich einen quantenmechanischen Algorithmus mit polynomiellen
Kosten für die ganzzahlige Faktorisierung.
Shors Algorithmus hat polynomielle Kosten und hat insbesondere qubit-Kosten, ähnlich wie die modulare Exponentiation.
Eine weitere Klasse von Problemen, mit der
du vielleicht vertraut bist, ist die Klasse der NP-vollständigen Probleme.
Ich werde in dieser Lektion nicht darauf eingehen, was NP-vollständige Probleme sind, aber du kannst sie
nachschlagen, wenn du interessiert bist.
Es wird vermutet, dass
keines dieser Probleme subexponentielle Kosten hat.
Das ist im Wesentlichen eine circuit-basierte Version dessen, was manchmal als
Exponentialzeithypothese bezeichnet wird, aber bisher hat niemand herausfinden können,
wie man es beweist.
Tatsächlich können wir nicht einmal beweisen, dass es keine Algorithmen mit linearen Kosten für NP-vollständige Probleme gibt.
Es ist einfach wirklich schwierig,
zumindest soweit wir wissen, die Möglichkeit einer zukünftigen Entdeckung eines unglaublich kreativen
Algorithmus für diese Probleme auszuschließen.
Hier ist eine Abbildung, die
das Verhältnis zwischen polynomiellen und exponentiellen Kosten veranschaulicht.
Auf der X-Achse haben wir die Eingabelänge für das jeweilige Problem, über das wir nachdenken, und die Y-Achse stellt die
Kosten dar, dieses Problem zu lösen,
oder du kannst dir das auch
als die Zeit vorstellen, die benötigt wird, das Problem zu lösen, wenn du das bevorzugst.
Ein Algorithmus mit exponentiellen Kosten
könnte so skalieren.
Bei kurzen Eingaben sind die Kosten möglicherweise nicht besonders hoch, wie etwa beim Faktorisieren der
Zahl 12,
aber wenn die Eingabelänge größer wird, werden die Kosten irgendwann explodieren.
Ein Algorithmus mit polynomialem Aufwand
hingegen könnte eine Skalierung haben, die so aussieht.
Die Kosten werden im Allgemeinen noch steigen, wenn die Eingaben länger werden, und könnten bei manchen Eingaben sogar höher sein als beim exponentiell kostspieligen
Algorithmus,
aber irgendwann wird er
deutlich günstiger sein als der Algorithmus mit exponentiellem Aufwand und explodiert nicht
auf die gleiche extreme Weise
wie Algorithmen mit exponentiellem Aufwand.
Wenn wir uns also vorstellen, dass wir
einen maximalen Aufwand haben, den wir bereit sind zu investieren, oder eine maximale Zeit, die wir bereit sind, auf eine Antwort zu warten,
wenn du lieber in Zeit denkst, dann funktioniert der Algorithmus mit exponentiellem Aufwand nur für Eingaben
bis zu einer bestimmten Länge,
wohingegen der
Algorithmus mit polynomialem Aufwand uns im Allgemeinen erlaubt, das
Problem für größere Eingaben zu lösen.
Und deshalb können wir beispielsweise ggT-Berechnungen für Zahlen mit vielen tausend
Bits leicht durchführen, aber im schlimmsten Fall
können wir Zahlen dieser Größe nicht faktorisieren.
Im letzten Teil der Lektion werden wir uns der Implementierung klassischer Berechnungen
auf Quantencomputern widmen.
Genauer gesagt werden wir
sehen, dass jede Berechnung, die von einem booleschen circuit durchgeführt werden kann, auch von einem Quanten-circuit durchgeführt werden kann
und das bei ungefähr gleichen Kosten. Außerdem kann das auf eine saubere Weise
geschehen, die wichtig ist, wenn wir
diese Berechnungen ausführen wollen
als Unterroutinen innerhalb
größerer Quantenberechnungen, und ich werde erklären, was ich mit „sauber" meine, wenn wir weiter in die Diskussion einsteigen.
Wir werden dabei
Toffoli gates einsetzen.
Zur Erinnerung: Toffoli gates sind controlled-controlled-NOT gates, ihre Wirkung auf Standardbasiszustände
ist so, wie du es hier auf dem Bildschirm siehst.
Beachte, dass wir uns
Toffoli gates auch als query gates
für die AND-Funktion vorstellen können.
Das soll nicht heißen, dass sie im wörtlichen Sinne query gates sind. Wie ich zu Beginn der Lektion erwähnt habe, arbeiten wir an diesem Punkt nicht im
Query-Modell,
sondern ihre Wirkung folgt demselben Muster wie ein query gate.
Wir können die binären Werte A und B als Eingaben für die AND-Funktion betrachten und wie bei einem query gate
werden diese Werte
als Teil der Ausgabe weitergegeben und der Wert der Funktion, also das logische AND von A und B,
wird auf das unterste qubit aufgeXORt. Wir haben Toffoli gates nicht in unser Standard-gate-Set aufgenommen.
Wir könnten unsere Meinung ändern, wenn wir wollten, aber wir müssen das eigentlich nicht
tun, weil wir alternativ Toffoli
gates mit Hadamard gates implementieren können,
T- und T-Dagger-gates
und controlled-NOT-gates, wie du hier siehst.
Es ist überhaupt nicht offensichtlich,
dass dieser bestimmte circuit ein Toffoli gate implementiert, aber das tut er, und du kannst mir entweder glauben
oder alles selbst durchrechnen, um etwas Übung zu bekommen, oder du kannst einfach Qiskit oder Python fragen
oder irgendeine Software, die Matrizen multipliziert, die Multiplikation für dich durchzuführen.
Und du kannst dir den
Lehrbuchinhalt zur Lektion ansehen, um zu sehen, wie das mit Qiskit gemacht wird.
Jetzt können wir dazu übergehen, boolesche gates mit Quanten-circuits zu simulieren, und alles, was wir
dafür brauchen, sind NOT gates,
controlled-NOT-gates und Toffoli gates.
Diese Operationen sind alle deterministisch, zusätzlich dazu, dass sie unitär sind, und manchmal beschreiben wir
solche Operationen als reversibel, und tatsächlich
geht die Erforschung reversibler Berechnungen dem Quantencomputing voraus, und daher stammt dieses gesamte
Verfahren eigentlich.
Die booleschen gates, um die wir uns
kümmern müssen, sind NOT gates, Hadamard gates und FANOUT gates,
und was wir zeigen werden, ist, dass wir diese gates implementieren oder simulieren können, wenn du
das bevorzugst, mit NOT gates,
controlled-NOT-gates und Toffoli gates.
Um es klar zu sagen: Wir
wollen Quanten-circuits, die es uns ermöglichen, die Werte der booleschen gates zu berechnen, die ich gerade erwähnt habe,
wenn wir ihnen qubits in
Standardbasiszuständen als Eingabe geben.
Bei beliebigen Quantenzustandseingaben wird die Wirkung
wie üblich durch Linearität bestimmt.
Wir müssen mit den NOT
gates nichts Besonderes machen. NOT gates sind NOT gates und sie können direkt implementiert werden.
Und OR gates können
mit Toffoli- und NOT-gates simuliert werden.
AND gates sind einfach, insbesondere angesichts dessen, was ich gerade vor wenigen Momenten über Toffoli gates gesagt habe, nämlich dass sie im Wesentlichen
query gate-Implementierungen
der AND-Funktion sind.
Genau gesagt können wir ein neues qubit einführen, das auf den Nullzustand initialisiert ist,
und dieses qubit zum
Ziel unseres Toffoli gates machen und die beiden Eingabe-
qubits zu den Steuerelementen.
Solchen zusätzlichen qubits
wie diesen, die häufig in
Quantenberechnungen eingeführt werden, werden verschiedene Namen gegeben, und ich nenne sie Workspace-
qubits, um einen Namen zu wählen.
Unsere typische Annahme bei Workspace-qubits ist, dass sie im Nullzustand beginnen und wir sie häufig wieder
in den Nullzustand zurückversetzen können,
wenn wir mit ihnen fertig sind, aber nicht immer.
Im Diagramm haben wir ein Ket-Null innerhalb des gestrichelten Rechtecks, um anzuzeigen, dass die
Initialisierung dieses qubits
Teil des Prozesses ist, und wenn du kein
frisches qubit wie dieses hast, wirst du
diese Simulation nicht durchführen können.
Das untere Ausgabe-qubit
ist das, das uns interessiert, denn das ist das Ergebnis
der AND-Operation, und mit den anderen beiden
sind wir im Grunde fertig.
Sie können also innerhalb der Box bleiben.
Du könntest dir sogar vorstellen, dass das Entfernen dieser beiden qubits Teil der Aufgabe ist,
dieses AND gate zu simulieren,
so etwas wie Müll, der
entsorgt werden muss.
Aber wie auch immer, so können wir
ein AND gate simulieren.
Da wir jetzt wissen, wie AND gates funktionieren, können wir OR gates mithilfe
eines der De Morganschen Gesetze umsetzen.
Wenn du NOT gates an die beiden Eingaben und an den Ausgang eines AND
gates anlegst, erhältst du ein OR gate – so einfach ist das.
Und das letzte ist FANOUT, und dafür brauchen wir nur
ein controlled NOT gate zusammen mit einem Arbeitsbereich-qubit.
Konkret: Wenn wir
das Arbeitsbereich-qubit als Ziel festlegen, kopieren wir effektiv jeden eingehenden Standard-Basiszustand,
sodass das wie ein FANOUT gate wirkt.
Wir haben also alle unsere gates.
Und jetzt, da wir alle unsere gates haben, können wir zu den circuits übergehen.
Nehmen wir an, wir haben
einen booleschen circuit namens C, und das kann ein beliebiger
boolescher circuit sein, den du wählst,
solange er aus
AND-, NOT- und FANOUT-gates besteht.
T sei die Anzahl der gates in C, und wir nennen F die Funktion, die C berechnet.
Wir können F also in der Form betrachten, die du hier siehst, wobei N die Anzahl der Eingabebits von C ist,
M die Anzahl der Ausgabebits und sigma das binäre Alphabet.
Und was wir tun, ist, die gates von C einfach einzeln der Reihe nach durchzugehen.
Die NOT gates lassen wir unverändert und ersetzen die anderen durch die Simulationen,
die ich gerade beschrieben habe.
Wenn C also so aussieht, erhalten wir einen circuit
R, der so aussieht.
In diesem Diagramm wurden alle
Arbeitsbereich-qubits, die wir für die Simulationen benötigen, aus ihren Boxen herausgezogen und unten gesammelt.
K ist also die Gesamtzahl der
Arbeitsbereich-qubits, die wir benötigen – eines für jedes gate von C, außer für die NOT gates.
Für die Ausgabe von R haben wir die qubits, die
dem Ausgang von C entsprechen, und hier sind diese qubits
oben dargestellt,
obwohl es am Ende keine Rolle spielen wird,
ob sie oben sind oder nicht.
Genauer gesagt: Angenommen, wir haben R auf einem Standard-Basiszustand ausgeführt, der einem
beliebigen N-Bit-String X entspricht,
dann werden diese M Ausgabe-qubits im Standard-Basiszustand
sein, der F von X entspricht.
Wir haben auch alle übrigen qubits von den AND- und OR-gates.
Wir müssen sie noch berücksichtigen, und wenn wir sie alle zusammenfassen, befinden sie sich in einem bestimmten Standard-Basiszustand.
Welcher Standard-Basiszustand das auch immer ist, er muss eine Funktion des Strings X sein, und dieser
Funktion geben wir den Namen G.
G ist also eine neue Funktion, die
durch die gates von C bestimmt wird und uns sagt, in welchem Zustand
diese übrigen qubits sind,
nachdem R ausgeführt wurde. G ist der nächste Buchstabe nach F – das ist ein Grund,
diese Funktion G zu nennen,
aber ein weiterer Grund, sie G zu nennen, ist, dass G kurz für Garbage (Müll) steht.
Das sind alles Garbage-qubits, und konkret haben wir
zwei Garbage-qubits für jedes AND gate und für jedes OR gate.
Die Gesamtzahl der gates,
die wir benötigen, ist big-O von T.
Das liegt daran, dass wir für jedes gate von C eine begrenzte Anzahl von Quanten-gates benötigen.
Das OR gate ist das aufwendigste. Dafür benötigen wir drei NOT gates sowie ein Toffoli-gate,
und ein Toffoli-gate kostet uns 15 gates aus unserem Standard-Gate-Set.
Das sind also höchstens 18 gates
in R für jedes gate von C.
Wenn du das optimieren möchtest, kannst du das tun, aber für eine
grobe asymptotische Analyse können wir einfach sagen, dass
R big-O von T gates hat.
Wir haben es also geschafft,
dieselbe Funktion F zu berechnen, die der ursprüngliche boolesche
circuit C berechnet hat,
und das zu einem Aufwand, der linear in der Größe von C ist.
Wenn wir nur daran interessiert sind,
diese Funktion F zu berechnen, sind wir fertig.
Leider haben wir aber
diese Garbage-qubits, und diese Garbage-qubits werden
im Allgemeinen die
Interferenzmuster zerstören, die Quantenalgorithmen zum Funktionieren bringen, wenn wir versuchen, diesen
circuit R als Subroutine zu verwenden,
innerhalb eines größeren Quantenalgorithmus.
Aber wir können diesen Müll tatsächlich
loswerden, und das gelingt uns, indem wir uns zunutze machen, dass der circuit R invertiert werden kann,
oder anders gesagt: wir können
ihn rückwärts ausführen.
Um zu veranschaulichen, wie das funktioniert, stellen wir uns vor, dass wir zuerst R ausführen und dann R rückwärts ausführen,
was wir als R Dagger ausdrücken können.
Um das klarzustellen: Das bedeutet, dass wir die gates
von R in umgekehrter Reihenfolge anwenden und die Inversen
jedes einzelnen gates nehmen.
NOT gates, controlled NOT
gates und Toffoli-gates sind tatsächlich ihre eigenen Inversen – wenn wir also in
diesen gates denken,
dann ist R Dagger wirklich nur R mit den gates
in umgekehrter Reihenfolge.
Aber im Allgemeinen können wir jeden unitären Quanten-circuit immer in umgekehrter Reihenfolge ausführen, so wie ich es gerade beschrieben habe,
das heißt, wir wenden die
gates in umgekehrter Reihenfolge an und ersetzen jeden der
einzelnen gates durch seine Inverse.
Wenn wir das täten, würden wir feststellen, dass zunächst R auszuführen und dann R in
umgekehrter Reihenfolge überhaupt nichts bewirkt.
Wenn wir also in einem Standardbasiszustand begonnen haben, wie wir ihn hier haben, würden wir in genau demselben Standardbasiszustand enden.
Das allein ist natürlich
nicht sehr hilfreich, aber was wir tun können, ist eine Reihe zusätzlicher qubits einzuführen, und zwar konkret
sind das M qubits, wobei M die Anzahl der Ausgabebits des circuit C ist.
Diese zusätzlichen qubits können
sich in einem beliebigen Quantenzustand befinden, aber um zu erklären, wie das funktioniert, nehmen wir an, dass sie sich in einem Standardbasiszustand befinden,
der einem String Y entspricht. Y ist also ein M-Bit-String, und was wir tun können, ist,
eine Reihe von kontrollierten NOT-
gates anzuwenden, wie du sie hier siehst, die den String F von X effektiv XOR-verknüpfen
mit dem String Y, der
in diesen unteren M qubits gespeichert ist.
Die Ausgabe der
gesamten Berechnung ist daher so, wie sie auf dem Bildschirm erscheint.
X und Y sind beliebige Binärstrings. X hat M-Bits und Y hat M-Bits, und wir benötigen außerdem K Workspace-qubits.
Wenn wir R ausführen, berechnen wir F von X und dieser String wird
in den oberen M qubits gespeichert, aber wir haben auch eine
Reihe von Garbage-qubits,
also XOR-verknüpfen wir die Ausgabe F von
X mit den unteren M qubits und führen dann R in umgekehrter Reihenfolge aus,
um den Garbage zu bereinigen.
Ich sollte darauf hinweisen, dass es wichtig ist, dass R deterministisch ist.
Wenn sich diese oberen M qubits stattdessen in einer Superposition von
Standardbasiszuständen befänden, würde das nicht korrekt funktionieren,
aber das funktioniert,
wenn R deterministisch ist.
Wenn wir also den Quanten-
circuit, den wir gerade gebaut haben, mit dem ursprünglichen Booleschen circuit C vergleichen, sehen wir, dass er im Grunde
genauso funktioniert,
wie ein Query-gate
für eine beliebige Funktion funktioniert.
Es gibt hier einen Unterschied, nämlich dass wir diese
Workspace-qubits brauchen, damit das alles funktioniert, aber ansonsten haben wir
effektiv ein Query-gate gebaut.
Oder einen Query-circuit für welche Funktion auch immer C berechnet.
Es ist uns übrigens auch gelungen, die Workspace-
qubits in ihren Anfangszustand zurückzuversetzen, sodass sie grundsätzlich wiederverwendet werden könnten.
Als Workspace-qubits für
nachfolgende Berechnungen.
Wenn wir möchten, können wir einen Kasten um den gesamten Quanten-circuit zeichnen, ihn Q nennen, und die Beziehung zu
C wird klarer.
Der circuit Q wird
im Allgemeinen größer sein als C. Wir benötigen für jeden gate von C eine Handvoll Quanten-
gates in Q,
und wir brauchen auch die kontrollierten
NOT-gates in der Mitte, aber die Anzahl ist immer noch
linear in der Größe von C.
Es sei auch darauf hingewiesen, dass dies ein vollständig allgemeines Verfahren ist, das für jeden Booleschen circuit funktioniert, und wir haben überhaupt nicht versucht, Q zu optimieren.
Für einen bestimmten circuit C könnte es durchaus
Möglichkeiten geben, die Größe von Q zu reduzieren, einschließlich der Verwendung von Methoden,
die die Anzahl der benötigten
Workspace-qubits reduzieren, falls das etwas ist,
das wir tun möchten, und das ist das Verfahren zum Ausführen von
klassischen Berechnungen
auf einem Quantencomputer.
Es ist ziemlich einfach, aber es ist eine wichtige
Sache, die man können muss.
Insbesondere sind wir jetzt, da wir
wissen, wie das geht, frei, beliebige klassische Berechnungen zu nutzen,
innerhalb von Quantenberechnungen, vorausgesetzt, wir folgen dieser Form, bei der die Eingabe gespiegelt wird und die Ausgabe XOR-verknüpft wird
mit einer Reihe von qubits,
genau wie wir es bei Query-gates hatten.
Die Kosten skalieren linear. Wir können also zum Beispiel
Quanten-circuits für Probleme wie die ganzzahlige Addition erstellen,
Multiplikation, Division, Berechnung von GCDs und modularer Exponentiation, und das alles kann mit den gleichen asymptotischen Kosten
wie bei Booleschen circuits durchgeführt werden.
Wir brauchen dafür zwar Workspace-qubits, aber zumindest können sie nach Gebrauch wieder verwendet werden.
Eine letzte Anmerkung, die es wert ist zu erwähnen, ist, dass diese Methode uns eine Möglichkeit bietet, Query-gates zu implementieren,
worauf ich in der vorherigen Lektion angedeutet hatte.
Das heißt, wenn wir einen Query-Algorithmus haben, der eine Funktion F als Eingabe nimmt, und wir eine Möglichkeit haben, F mit einem Booleschen circuit zu berechnen,
dann können wir diesem Verfahren folgen, um ein Query-gate für diese Funktion zu bauen und dann unseren Query-Algorithmus darauf auszuführen.
Ob das eine nützliche Sache ist oder nicht, hängt vom Query-Problem selbst ab und davon, was wir erreichen wollen, aber im Wesentlichen bietet uns diese
Konstruktion
eine Möglichkeit, das Query-Modell mit einem standardmäßigeren Berechnungsmodell zu verbinden.
Das ist in gewissem Sinne die Funktionsweise von Shors Algorithmus zur ganzzahligen Faktorisierung.
Wir werden
Quanten-circuits wie diesen aus einigen der arithmetischen Operationen aufbauen, über die wir früher in der Lektion gesprochen haben.
Und dadurch geben wir
Quanten-circuits die Fähigkeit, diese Operationen auf Superpositionen klassischer Zustände auszuwerten.
Und wie wir sehen werden, ermöglicht uns das, ganze Zahlen effizient zu faktorisieren.
Das ist das Ende dieser Lektion, die sich hauptsächlich darauf konzentriert hat, eine Grundlage
für Quantenalgorithmen in einem standardmäßigen Nicht-Blackbox-
Berechnungsrahmen zu schaffen.
Wir haben über Berechnungskosten hauptsächlich durch die Linse von Problemen gesprochen, die mit der grundlegenden Zahlentheorie zusammenhängen.
Wir haben polynomielle
versus exponentielle Kosten für Berechnungsaufgaben besprochen, und wir haben gesehen, wie klassische Berechnungen
durch Quanten-circuits auf eine saubere, garbage-freie Weise implementiert werden können, die es ermöglicht, sie als Subroutinen zu verwenden,
innerhalb größerer Quantenberechnungen.
Ich hoffe, du machst in der nächsten Lektion mit, wo wir sehen werden, wie Shors Algorithmus diese Ideen nutzt und es uns ermöglicht, ganze Zahlen
mit polynomiellen Kosten zu faktorisieren.
Auf Wiedersehen bis dahin.